it's great to be joined today by dr.
Michael Shermer who's the publisher of
skeptic magazine a New York Times
bestselling author and monthly columnist
for Scientific American Michael there's
just so much to talk about with you and
I'm so glad to have the opportunity I'd
love to start a little bit with your
background you're known to many people
now is not only a skeptic but as a
non-religious guy but that has sort of
not always been the case I mean even
though you weren't raised particularly
religious you had a phase of your life
where you were quite a bit more
religious can you talk about sort of how
that happened yeah I certainly was and
thanks for having me on I appreciate
that the it really began in high school
in the early 70s with the kind of Mesa
born-again movement this was kind of the
beginnings of the rise of the
evangelical right in America in which
there was a general rejection of
organized religion but a rehab facility
endure ectly to God by reading the Bible
yourself and going to Bible classes and
Bible study sessions and get-together
social gatherings things like that and
so I did that it mostly just kind of a
social peer kind of thing not for my
parents or teachers but from my peers
and friends and I really got into it I
went to Pepperdine University and I was
going to major in theology and you know
I wit I witnessed to people you know I
went door-to-door I Evangelos which is
the very definition of an evangelical as
you're supposed to go out and tell
people the good news about Jesus is your
savior and all that so I did that and
you know it made perfect coherent sense
internal logic internally logical when
you're in that bubble that echo chamber
is we now call it when I was at
Pepperdine surrounded by fellow
believers and it's not like we never
heard any counter arguments but you
don't really get the serious arguments
until you get out of the bubble and so
when I went to graduate school to study
experimental sight and I was surrounded
by secular people just I don't know if
they were religious or not it just
wasn't relevant no one cared and there
was no big a theism theism debate at the
time it was just not a cultural thing
and and so it just kind of faded away
for me I you know I took courses in
anthropology and realize
at all these others religions these
people that believe just as strongly as
I did and you know what are the chances
that I happen to be the one that got it
right and all these other people are
wrong or maybe it's all socially
constructed and that's what I ended up
concluding and and then just kind of
quietly gave up my religiosity now
there's no no big thing I think some of
my friends and family were actually
relieved because I stopped evangelizing
you know which can get obnoxious at
dinners and things like that so and that
you know to them I just really got into
science because that's what I was
studying anyway and and then that kind
of became my worldview as it were human
it secular humanism science science and
reason so let's pick up on that because
there's a talking point that we often
hear from people who are strong
adherents to religious faith which is
listen you could believe in religion or
you can believe in science and they're
sort of equivalent epistemology is
although they wouldn't necessarily use
the term epistemology what's the best
way to approach that false equivalency
in a sort of objective manner yeah I
think it you know if you push people of
faith on what they need by faith usually
it does come down to some leap an
epistemological leap of which they admit
you know there's certain things we can't
prove but are just the tenets of our
religion for example the resurrection of
Jesus we could argue that someone named
Jesus probably did exist some atheists
argue against that but I can decide with
people like Barger Minh and say yeah I
probably existed he's a religious
scholar and atheist and then he was
probably crucified because you know in
Romans crucified everybody so that's not
neither one of those are particularly
extraordinary claims but the claim that
he was then resurrected from the dead
died for your sins those sorts of things
not only is there no evidence for there
can't be I mean in a way it's it's kind
of a religious tenet that belongs only
to Christians because Jews who are just
as smart as Christians and Muslims
scholars who are just as smart as
Christian scholars you know they don't
accept the resurrection or that Jesus
was the Savior the Messiah and so on so
why not and the answer is pretty obvious
because it's not an article of faith of
their religion so
those are the kinds of things the
deepest central tenets of a particular
religion are not nothing at all like
science there's no empirical test you're
going to run to decide whether it's true
or not
whereas in science we have these set of
methods that evolved over centuries to
weed out that very process of just
believing because that's what we've
always done or just believing because it
feels good and so those techniques then
allow us to test hypotheses and see if
we're right or wrong and it's not that
scientists have some special I don't
know a moral commitment to truth more
than religious people
it's just that scientists are trained to
look for their own mistakes and biases
and errors because if they don't
somebody else in the field will and so
there's kind of a social pressure in a
particular community of scientists
working on some field some area that if
you don't try to get it right really and
not fudge your data or bias your data
even unconsciously somebody else is
going to get it going to nail you on it
so there's kind of a pressure to not go
too far with your evidence and and
there's nothing like that in religion
and that's the difference Michael there
are some non-believers who when asked
their views on religion take a sort of
standoffish approach of hey listen
people can believe whatever they want to
believe as long as we're maintaining
separation of church and state for
example at least within the United
States not all countries have that that
tenets as part of their government as
long as they're not going out and
hurting other people or negatively
impacting other people's lives I don't
really care what people believe doesn't
seem hugely damaging to me there are
other non-believers who say no if you
are basing your worldview around an
epistemology that is that is a
structured around faith in other words
belief without evidence it doesn't
matter whether you're hurting other
people or not that's something we should
proactively try to sort of stop or make
people rid themselves of are you closer
to one side or the other on that debate
yeah that's a hard one that's well put
the best examples I've heard of
outlining that issue and and I can go
both ways I mean on on good days when I
you know I'm concerned about other
things you know like politics or how the
economy is going or possible war with
North Korea things like that then I
don't really care what people believe as
long as they don't fly planes into
buildings or blow up abortion clinics or
you know leave me alone you know but at
other times I do I do feel like once you
go down the road of accepting things
based on a lack of evidence just faith
or just because it feels right that that
can be kind of a gateway drug to other
beliefs so it's you know the problems
say of extreme Islamic terrorism in a
way the beliefs that the terrorists fold
in you know a supernatural being that
Sharia law is God's law and God handed
down these laws you know these these are
the same kind of beliefs that moderate
Muslims hold they all hold the same
beliefs so it's what do you do with it
so the problem again is extremism but it
would be better if people didn't hold
those supernatural beliefs in the first
place so we don't even have to have a
foundation for that kind of activity
that behavior that is terrorism and it's
not I'm not picking on religion here I
mean thirty years ago you and I would
have been talking about radical Marxist
terrorists who were in the 70s blowing
up airplanes and in the name of you know
revolutionary Marxism which is an
atheist or non believing it's you know
non religious based ideology so it all
depends on what people do with the
belief so it does matter in the end
what's actually true because that it
ultimately can push people's behavior
one direction or another when you have
conversations with people who hold
beliefs that in your mind are not based
on evidence what's your sort of approach
and the to contextualize this we not
that long ago interviewed Peter Bogosian
whose book a manual for creating
atheists takes a relatively Socratic
method of questioning approach and
creating some degree of doubt about
beliefs and sort of bearing in mind that
may be aggressive con
imitations on particular beliefs are not
as useful as making someone reexamine
why they believe what they believe in
the first place can you give us a sense
of sort of your approach and it doesn't
even have to be with religion it could
be with climate change I mean it really
could could be with anything yeah and
you know pizza good friend and I like
his approach that Socratic you know I
just have one more questions it's just
one little question here one little
niggle I want to get at just then you
get to sort of pull the people out of
you know their their stance and get them
to see it from your perspective and of
course they're trying to do the same
thing with you that's all fine and so my
approach generally that I've developed
over the years and by temperament I'm
kind of this way anyway it's not to be
too confrontational because the moment
you attack somebody the wall goes up and
they're no longer even listening to you
they're insulted and so we know from
psychological research on cognitive
dissonance that if you confront somebody
in the wrong way with facts that counter
their deepest held beliefs they will not
only reject the facts they'll double
down on their beliefs and this is what
the core of cognitive dissonance
sometimes called a backfire effect you
know so you you're talking to a climate
denier climate skeptic and you throw at
them the ice core data and the tree-ring
data and the parts per million increase
over the last century versus the
previous hundred thousand years and you
know all just marshals clearly to your
position and they just double down on
their skepticism okay what's going on
there well because it really isn't about
those facts that's very relevant what
they want to know is if I believe this
stuff that you're telling me does that
mean I have to give up my most deep
deepest important beliefs about the
economy and free markets and small
government and you know because I know
those liberals are going to go and pass
all those laws and interfere into the
into the marketplace and restrict
government a restricted industry and
business and I don't like that and so I
try to do an end run around it by saying
you know look you don't have to give up
anything you know capitalism is great
and here's a super opportunity that to
make a lot of money in startups and be
an entrepreneur
that saves the environment makes a lot
of money or something like that same
thing with I'm talking to a religious
person about evolution and they if they
feel like you know if I accept this
Darwin guy and his theory does I'm gonna
have to be an atheist I have to give up
all my morals it doesn't mean we're you
know there's no basis of morality and
America is going to go to hell in a
handbasket because we're not a Christian
nation anymore it's is that with this
Darwin stuff means no no no just take
that off the table let's just accept the
science for what it is and we can talk
about the moral thing later
you know in other words got to diffuse
the deeper concerns that somebody like
that has so they could at least listen
to you they're not even listening then
there's no point in even advair
conversation let's pick up our
conversation there we've been speaking
with dr. Michael Shermer we will
continue our conversation with him on
tomorrow's program
we're continuing our conversation with
dr. Michael Shermer publisher of skeptic
magazine a New York Times bestselling
author also a monthly columnist for
Scientific American we sort of paused
our conversation in the first part
Michael talking about some strategies
you have for attempting to make others
open to maybe other other ideas or other
beliefs I think that this is sort of a
natural transition into some of your
work in the skeptic community and with
regard to conspiracy theories and maybe
we could start at the broadest possible
level I'd love to hear a little bit from
you about why you believe conspiracy
theories generally speaking can be so
gripping and appealing to individuals
and what one idea I've had is that to
some degree there is probably an aspect
of conspiracy theories that is calming
to some in that if you can figure out
who really did this or that that's much
easier for someone to sort of live with
than the possibility that there are
random events or at least events that we
can not control that's far scarier in
some sense what do you think yeah
perfectly put absolutely that's one of
the several factors that go into
conspiratorial thinking first it's good
to acknowledge that there are
conspiracies that really do happen I
mean Lincoln was assassinated by a
conspiracy Watergate was a conspiracy
you know the recent NSA revelation you
know the WikiLeaks revelations about the
NSA you know they're something of a
conspiracy going on there we'd like to
know what's really going on fair enough
then the theories about the conspiracies
that's a whole other thing and so in
general the psychology behind it is you
know exactly what you said it kind of we
sense that maybe there's something else
afoot and we want to know well what is
it and it turns out that a lot of
history turns on randomness and the
reason that's uncomfortable is because
you can't do anything about it there's
no controls you know the economy is a
super complex thing and there's you know
there's very little we can do predicting
the price of gas for example no one
knows
what I mean I'd really rather know that
you know twelve people in the Illuminati
and in London are determining wars and
the outcomes of economic crises and
things like that it's so it's a sense of
control a sense of that things happen
for a reason rather than randomness this
is also a religious impulse that you
know nothing happens by chance
everything happens for a reason I went
left instead of right at the stairwell
and my life is saved the classic story
from 9/11 and you know it just in terms
of just how it cognition and how it
feels emotionally up about how you
engage the world a conspiracy theory
kind of wraps a structure around it and
I and I can see where I fit into this
thing and that you know very comforting
so that's that's a big part of it I
think and when you I mean you've dealt
with everything from sort of political
conspiracy theories to claims about the
paranormal cults pseudoscience
everything in between are there well let
me let me put it this way is there some
thread that unites all of those areas
and are there particular differences
between for example beliefs about the
paranormal pseudoscience and political
conspiracy theories that really separate
out those different categories
yeah I think one of those common threads
is is power who has it who wants it
and so most conspiracy theories are
constructed by people who don't have the
power who think someone else does have
power in particular power over them or
their lives and so we tend to
overestimate as Outsiders the power of
say CEOs or corporations or government
agencies about what they can really do
and unfortunately occasionally big CEOs
corporations and government agencies and
politicians really do have power and
abuse it so it's probably in a way good
that we have a little bit of skepticism
about about power people in power and
this is why the founders constructed our
government the way it is with checks and
balances because people do conspire to
you know pocket you can event
themselves and their relatives over the
general populace when they're supposedly
public figures and and that's why we we
do have a conspiratorial bent there that
it's probably good that but of course
that you know you spin Xin to something
like an Alex Jones type rant about you
know every single politician is in on it
thousands of government corporate you
know CEOs are conspiring to you know run
the run the world or something like that
you know there it goes off the rails so
is it just a couple gentle talking
points the more people that have to be
involved in a conspiracy the less likely
it is to be true
the more elements that have to come
together just right for it to happen the
less likely it is to be true people
can't keep secrets people are not that
competent government agencies are not
that efficient you know and and then
finally there's kind of this idea I talk
about cognitive dissonance in our last
episode and so with cognitive harmony we
want to balance there so you take
something like the Holocaust the worst
genocide in history and committed by the
Nazi regime one of the worst political
regimes in history so there's kind of a
sense of balance there but if you take
someone like the assassination of JFK by
a lone nut you know so the Lee Harvey
Oswald lone nothing just doesn't jive
it's like how can this great four or
nine eleven you know nineteen guys with
box cutters you know come on
really that just doesn't about we want
and we want all these other things in
there you know it was Bush
administration and you know all these
other covert operations were at work and
it was a false flag operation and then
to go to war on this stuff rather than
the Bush administration took took
advantage of this thing that happened to
then push their political agenda which
all governments administrations do you
know that the random element is what we
don't like and that's probably explains
a lot more history than the conspiracy
theories do the this idea of sort of
like a coherent narrative not that long
ago I read Thinking Fast and Slow by the
great Daniel Kahneman and when he talks
about some of the cognitive biases that
as humans we can sort of fall prey to a
lot of it has to do with we overestimate
our ability
to intuitively determine whether there's
a pattern or whether there's randomness
where something makes sense or whether
it doesn't and it seems that there might
be a lot of overlap between that and
what what you're talking about in terms
of skepticism and debunking is it there
oh absolutely yes so this process I
called pattern insidee the tendency to
find meaningful patterns and both
meaningful and meaningless noise and the
problem is is we don't have a good error
detection system in our brains for
determining which patterns are real and
which are not which is why we need
science you know like things like
climate change
you can't just Intuit it you can't just
think well it was cold yesterday so I
guess global warming is not real and we
can't see the long-term trends over
hundreds of years or thousands of years
because our senses are not geared to
that we're really bad at gambling and
and investments and and probabilities
and statistics because our brains are
not geared toward understanding big
numbers a lot of large numbers and
things like that and really take some
kind of you know override about those
intuitions you have so Kahneman's
absolutely right about that are our
instincts kick in and we think well i
really have a sense of what's right and
sometimes you do but sometimes you don't
and that's why we need science can we
talk a little bit about some tools that
might apply ideally as broadly as
possible so to everything from
particular religious claims to
conspiracy theories some ways in which
our audience could sort of prepare
themselves to not get tricked or suede
or bamboozled by what might seem like a
pretty appealing case it could be a
religious belief it could be a
conspiracy theory it could be
pseudoscience at the foundational level
how can as thinkers people in the
audience start to evaluate different
claims yeah so the begins of the
principle proportionality which
proportion our confidence in a claim
based on the amount of evidence for it
the little quip we have in scepticism
Upton attributed to Carl Sagan but it
was actually said by somebody else is
another issue how quotes gravitate up to
the most famous person who ever said
them extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
so back to the story of the resurrection
I mentioned before it's not an
extraordinary claim to think that
someone named Yeshua Jesus existed in
the first century that was a common name
it's not an extraordinary claim that
somebody was crucified the Romans
crucified people right and left what is
an extraordinary claim is the
resurrection and the evidence is not
proportional to that extraordinary
Nassif that it's back to less than
extraordinary
so therefore skepticism would be a
reasonable position to take more
recently you know I was something of a
climate skeptic in the 90s because
frankly I just didn't think we had the
evidence for it yet but by the 2000s I
changed my mind because we haven't
started piling up so I proportioned my
confidence in that theory based on how
much evidence it was for it and in
general that's a good way to look at any
particular claim it's done upon us
although when you have very very
well-spoken people like to take the
religious world people like Ray Comfort
and William Lane Craig who you'll listen
to them for 15 minutes and you will sort
of say wow it's they put together such a
coherent narrative it makes perfect
sense
how can one protect themselves against
that well first of all in that case if
they're just doing philosophy if they're
just making logical arguments that that
is part of reason in the Western
tradition of thinking fine but at some
point you should look out the window to
see you know there's some correspondence
with nature with reality a lot of times
these convoluted logical arguments take
you down a path that ends up being you
know nowhere because they're you know
there's like 20 steps in between where
you begin and where you end it that that
maybe we should have run an experiment
or test or see if the data supports it
or not that's where the empiricism part
of science comes in yes
reason logic but also look out the
window and see if it's true or not
because we can fool ourselves pretty
easily with those kinds of arguments
I've debated William Lane Craig super
smart guy and you know but but the flaws
are that he relies completely on these
arguments about insanity and first cause
prime mover
these go back centuries to medieval
philosophers early modern philosophers
and you know scientists just don't think
that way and that's why most scientists
are not religious or their religious
skeptics because you know at some point
if you can't test it then it's
reasonable to be skeptical it doesn't
mean we know there's no God for example
but it doesn't mean we should
necessarily believe just because you
know there's some logical argument for
it that makes sense and and always we're
the first and easiest person to fool
because all of us as Kahneman showed you
know our intuitive type one thinkers
initially we just you know it just seems
right it just sounds good it feels right
those are not good ways to you know run
your life because at some point you
should introduce type two thinking you
know deliberative rational careful
apportioned beliefs based on how much
evidence there is we have been speaking
with dr. Michael Shermer he is the
publisher of skeptic magazine you can
also check out his monthly columns for
Scientific American and his New York
Times best-selling books
Michael thank you so much for talking to
us really really appreciate up thank you
thanks for having me I appreciate that